this is a pepper panic saga level 232
walkthrough tutorial video this is a
pretty tough level so i am going to
play through it and beat it and explain
why I am doing what I do
when I go this level takes a while so
much rather play a little bit
on the fast side but if you played
already know that the hard part is
getting to the statues
there's no way to make matters down here
and there's Creighton way and get so
what we need to do in the areas hit
router creates
room do that by making shockwave matches
here we have a choice between 20 min ago
and she
the stage to great instead because it
takes to its here
sooner we don't really have any other
shockwaves already set up so
you can see we have a guest here that we
can drop on their own pool drug selling
them
and Sheena
tree this is really all
are you you know this is throughout
their level this is what you have
your set these up with not always easy
but that's really
what you're trying to do or are three
can see we have the gaps
here we can set this one up directly
rule is
this is set up and will everything
stay with them but at that
that's why I did that on there because
he
the cat is in the big he's not really
that big a deal on this level
is kinda just an annoyance
from you coach other plant
where he's going to move stuff out your
way but most the time
you just really isn't a factor
there
what I mean is is that we're not trying
to grow peppers for explosions
at all it or the only my if we have the
right word to the bottom but
other than that like if you have a match
I'll try to find a spot if you match
coming up in NorCal take the rezoning
pepper then my
way to turn otherwise I'd nor
in this conflict in chocolate
alright so here's a spot where
we have a green pepper the 3 to explode
so even if we had some
I don't see any but if we had some
chocolate matters to be a good idea to
explore this paper
motha those who really rivers or there's
a couple reasons why are there so we got
riverboats
statues and the other is later on the
level
a lot of times these yellow peppers will
fill up the whole bottom you will have
very many at the top so
this is nice that we have at least a
balloon a purple
here now that we might be over it's more
these crates are still our number one
priority
but since we have booze near two of them
if we can set up shock waves and will
try to assign
which are explored paper
your part over No here the right we have
to bring this down
check to see if there's anything else
first
him think so nurses purple
let us match the green kessel close
another thing to pay attention is some
unease rose now are
the for me more
for too late to get rid of this crate
miss with a lot more important
both
to know you have a shot with them yes I
will go and take the
have one large blue paper here but no
overall their own
go along with it so we're better off not
grow in this at all right and
place for later your party the gap on
the top here that no imouto
really make this cream and who's going
to slide all the so
where and innovation this hoping to get
lucky there
I i did. Getty other changer here pretty
quick
nothing doing over here
so we have a gap for the Blues murder
mysteries
bring in Seattle Boudreau okay
so
know everything's pretty much customer
so the fastest way to get some stuff
turns into here were
her to immerse in the air here so will
try to get her for the job
its Canada tedious process for yourself
you play before you know
alright this
this the well hit this stature round
pick
know you have some more blue in blue and
we have a
sometime before he's gonna get back
their owners field so
we can send a shock wave here then
grown blues are a pretty good idea
the one of the problems is that we have
a lot of big reno the purple so
as my and exploding
accidentally or on the process
this is kinda interesting this so that
the statue so it's a good shot but
this water in a question they may
explode this to leave them
another big one behind well these are
great movie will be the
truthful
it could go either way there's no other
buoyant
right here right now say it was good for
her and
right now we have two big blooms and
to important spots through wind up we
want to try to get rid try to get those
grown before he takes them
a congruent here
this from lose for sure
yes sir
reason why didn't like that will miss
kisser who's gonna go of this I but so
could end up working out pretty
alright so earlier well
it all worked out we're the shower
usually
I am when you have just one left it's
gonna be
like I said these yellow ones in the
fall into place a lot or the end
they can block them says he'll be better
if you only have one i think thats how
to set up the shockwave we got lucky
here at this rate there but
you know that I have never seen an
example where we can actually get them
yours to explore the bottom this is not
enough for the top so
if you get into that situation and just
try to
set up a shockwave the last war or you
know in this case you're the purple I
would go for the purple
or the green if you had a whole bunch
along
one is going to improve at all and
mislead you its this is really pressure
level weaker like it because
million there's some thinking and all
this other
fastest I've heard of it will work out
for just hang in there
if you're if you're actively setting up
a shot to the top in taking the time
like we did just their
you will be able to set up enough for
them to get through it
them you know it it's in
is not her lover that gonna be
consistently it took us a couple tries
here though those are heard until we got
it and
yesterday only player for the first time
it took a bunch of them so
just hang in there and the any questions
leave a comment make sure you like her
are Facebook page make sure that you
share this if you
found it helpful so that people can home
get passes levels well
but I hope you'll and will be making
more than
morning videos thanks